[Music]
a lot of people are also working from
home at the moment and that's something
I've been doing now for 10 or 11 years I
haven't been working for a company from
home I'm self-employed as many of you
know as well as running the Pioneer I
also have a writing business and I also
make apps etc and I combine all these
different things in order to create a
kind of lifestyle that I enjoy for me
personally I love working from home I'm
naturally an introvert
I'm very anti-authority and I like to
take my own time and work at my own pace
however I know that a lot of you are not
used to it and you're having a
difficulty coming to terms with it
so I thought I'd share some of my tips
and in this video I want to share just
one tip the one that I think has been
the most important for me and allowed me
to continue doing this for all these
years and that's to create
accountability because the danger is
that now that you work from home and I
was breathing over your neck you just
kind of lose all structure and all
motivation you roll out of bed at 11
a.m. you do your teeth and have lunch
and then you start work at 12 p.m. and
you work until 7 p.m. but half that time
he's been procrastinating so you didn't
really finish then you go out with
friends for some drinks and you come
home and do some more work up 1 a.m. and
I'm talking from experience here because
when I first left the university I moved
in with my mate and we lived together
and I was going out with other mates and
I lived right in the center of town in
Bournemouth town which has got a great
nightlife so yeah I had a terrible
work-life balance and I had a terrible
routine I was in a long-distance
relationship with Hannah my now wife and
we'd talked on MSN every night and just
I would often end up going to bed like
3:00 in the morning or 4:00 in the
morning and then waking up at 1:00 p.m.
in the afternoon going to a cafe and
working but then not finishing when
everyone came home and it was just
stressful and I got more and more behind
for things looked up once I started
being more accountable and created more
accountability for my work so a lot of
productivity books and gurus will talk
about creating stakes setting stakes for
your work so you might say I need to
write 3,000 words for this novel every
day even though the due date is miles in
the distance and if I don't complete
those words then I'm going to tell my
friend to check in on me and if I
haven't done it they're gonna donate
some of my money to charity or they're
gonna post something embarrassing on my
facebook wall likewise people use this
they wake up early in the mall
they have alarm clocks that humiliate
them if they don't turn them off in time
and this is a big movement and lots of
people really swear by it in fact there
are whole communities of people who
would just punish each other for not
doing stuff personally I think that this
is kind of artificial there's always
ways of getting around this kind of
thing you can always just turn off the
app or you can beg your friend or
whatever and it's too disconnected from
what you're doing and to me as well it's
not intrinsically motivating when you're
doing something to avoid a punishment
kind of puts you in the wrong headspace
for me personally anyways I don't like
it so instead I just create
accountability so what I've done for
years is I go to my clients and I say
even though the deadline is at this date
I'm going to provide you an X amount of
work every single day and then every
single day I send them that amount of
work and because I'm quite conscientious
and I don't like letting people down or
basically cuz I'm an egomaniac and I
don't like to look like I've failed I
will always meet that deadline I will
always fulfill what I've just told them
I'm gonna do even if that means staying
up late or if it means taking some kind
of personal hit but because of that I've
owned a stable amount of money every
single day without failure I know that
because I've told the client I'm gonna
earn that much I'm gonna do that much
work that I will do it and I will earn
that much and that's I can actually
predict how much salary I'm gonna have
at the end of the month which is really
useful if like me you're self-employed
for you guys who are maybe working from
home throw your usual employer you can
do the exact same thing if you're
working on a project just say I want to
send you this at the end of every day to
show you how much I've done and I'm
gonna aim to do this amount is that okay
and sure they might not want to look at
it but if you explain to them that this
is how you gonna motivate yourself
I'm sure they'll play along in the idea
now is that you have accountability and
the job itself is something that you
can't avoid doing there's no way around
it you can't put it off until tomorrow
and then end up realizing that tomorrow
is just as busy you're just as tired you
have to do it now because you've got
someone looking at it it's also forced
to you to kind of do a better quality
job etc and then the great thing about
this is that once you have that target
that daily goal and once you have that
accountability it gives you the freedom
to now be flexible and take full
advantage of working from home because
let's say you're a right turn you're
writing three thousand words a day if
that's your goal and you meet that
target by 2:00 p.m. now suddenly you can
rest until 5:00 p.m. guilt-free or do
something else or alternatively you can
get a head start tomorrow
work an extra three hours and then save
that bit finish it
at 12 p.m. the next day and I've got a
half day this gives you the flexibility
to start using lifestyle design to
change your routine however you like in
order to start enjoying the free time
because a lot of people who are
self-employed or work from home end up
half working for twice the time and as
such they don't they never release which
tauf but they never really fully
productive but if you know exactly how
much you've got to do and if you train
yourself over time to complete that
amount suddenly you've got the
flexibility to decide how you want to
design your day now you can start taking
full advantage of what it means to work
from home and if you're really
productive you can have a whole day off
as a result or you can work on something
else another side project and that's how
I built the Pioneer rave all these years
was by writing a certain amount every
day becoming productive enough to finish
it on time or early so that I could work
on the buyer near and these days I do my
work in four days a week so that I have
one day a week to work on the bian ear
and make these videos let's face it in
the office people wasted loads of time
you might go and speak to people around
the water cooler you probably have loads
of meetings that are completely
unhelpful this is called communication
overhead or you might just go and have a
long cigarette if you do that or have a
long dump in the toilet whatever the
case you probably waste a lot of time in
the office and that's because you have
to be there set amount of time when you
work from home you can remove all that
and you can stick it all on the end of
your day and just have a big chunk of
enjoyment and relaxation the problem is
like I say is lots of us don't do that
we end up half working throughout the
day working slowly dragging our heels
just because we're so used to the idea
that we work from nine till five or nine
till six but it doesn't have to be that
way now with a set target you can sit
down at 9:00 a.m. and no that's all
you've got to finish and it makes it
much easier if you just stay motivated
and finish it but one more thing I will
say is that this does take time and
effort just like anything else this is a
skill I started off working only able to
write four thousand words a day these
days I write sometimes up to 20,000
words and my record was 30,000 words a
day I could never have done that at the
start I could never have been
disciplined enough or got into enough of
a flow state but now I can because I
practiced it and the same thing will
happen to you you might not love working
from home right now but if you stick at
it if you keep trying to be productive
and use some of the tips that I posted
in my last video on productivity then
you'll find it becomes easier to write
more and more quickly or to enter more
data or to do more coding or
as you do and eventually they'll give
you the freedom and the flexibility to
start designing your lifestyle how you
want it so that's something a bit
different hopefully it was useful and
interesting for you if it was then
please leave like and share it around
that'll help me out immensely comment
down below if you're working from home
now and let's know the tips and methods
you're using to get more done take the
guys while staying safe and healthy
during this weird time and I'll see you
next time thanks Sten for watching and
bye for now